[Musik]
längst nicht in trockenen tüchern das
europaparlament fordert nachbesserungen
beim vom eu-gipfel beschlossenen
finanzpaket zwölf monate zur bundeswehr
ab april sollen die ersten freiwilligen
für dienst im heimatschutz ausgebildet
werden und jürgen klopp im fußballhimmel
sein fc liverpool hält nach 30 jahren
erstmals wieder die meisterschafts
trophäe in den händen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport norbert lehmann ein
sogenannter von mir von einer bitteren
pille spricht sogar eben
kommissionschefin ursula von der leyen
einige der entscheidungen auf die sich
die 27 eu länder beim sondergipfel
geeinigt haben seien schmerzhaft und
bedauerlich damit gibt sie dem
europäischen parlament recht das dem
finanzpaket so nicht zustimmen will und
stattdessen nach verhandlungen fordert
kritik gibt es vor allem am geplanten
haushalt zu wenig geld für gesundheit
und forschung den klimaschutz und
bildungsprogramme wie erasmus und was
die korona hilfen betrifft fordern die
abgeordneten wer sich nicht an
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien wie
pressefreiheit und eine unabhängige
justiz hält der sollte weniger geld
bekommen aus brüssel berichtet glück war
die ablehnung war deutlich auch wenn der
ratsvorsitzende michelle und
kommissionschefin von der leyen das
finanzpaket als bestmöglichen kompromiss
darstellten zwar begrüßten die meisten
abgeordneten das corona hilfsprogramm
zur bekämpfung der krise nicht aber die
im gegenzug vorgeschlagenen
haushaltskürzungen nichts als kürzungen
dramatische kürzungen im
gesundheitsprogramm mitten in corona
zeiten unglaublich 1074 milliarden euro
will die eu in den nächsten sieben
jahren ausgeben gestrichen wurde bei der
forschung statt 13 nur noch fünf
milliarden euro und der bildung beim
erasmus austauschprogramm auch bei
migration grenzsicherung und klimaschutz
mittel die den ausstieg aus der kohle
abfedern sollten zusammengestrichen von
30 auf 10 milliarden
wo sind die ambitionen der mut für
reformen wo ist der aufbruch in die
zukunft im moment sieht es so aus als
bedeute next generation das sich um die
klimakrise um die digitalisierung um die
gesundheit die nächste generation
kümmern soll und nicht wir
das ist inakzeptabel auch beim thema
rechtsstaatlichkeit will das parlament
weit mehr als die regierungschefs
freie presse unabhängige justiz die
gleichstellung von frau und mann
gewerkschaftlich organisiert sind keine
güter die man für ein paar milliarden
verramschen kann mit großer mehrheit
verabschiedete das parlament eine
resolution in der nachverhandlungen zum
finanzpaket gefordert werden
und jetzt zu den neuen corona zahlen
derzeit sind den behörden in deutschland
6200 akute fälle bekannt bei den
neuinfektionen gibt es auch heute einen
leichten anstieg im schnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 480 menschen angesteckt gestern
lag der durchschnitt noch bei 470 und
die sorge bleibt dass die zahlen
deutlicher steigen könnten gerade jetzt
in ferienzeiten wenn so viele menschen
kreuz und quer auf reisen sind
wer in risikogebieten war muss sich
testen lassen oder 14 tage in quarantäne
aber infizieren kann man sich natürlich
nicht nur in risikogebieten an seinem
stern berichtet die virus krise immer
mit dabei in diesen sommerferien
urlauber die nach hause kommen mit dem
virus passiert ist das zum beispiel in
cottbus eine ganze familie die eltern
und zwei kinder positiv getestet nach
der rückkehr von mallorca aufgefallen
sei das nur weil der arbeitgeber eines
elternteils einen corona test verlangte
so die behörden es ist natürlich auch
der umsicht des arbeitgebers und der
umsicht und dem verhalten der familie zu
verdanken dass die vier fälle entdeckt
worden sind und möglicherweise eine
weitere ausbreitung in der stadt oder
auch auf anderen wegen jetzt erstmal
verhindert und eingedämmt werden kann
eindämmen das ist das ziel nur wie mehr
tests mehr solche teststationen an den
flughäfen sollen her
doch die gesundheitsministerinnen noch
immer und die zeit drängt
es wird höchste zeit dass die
gesundheitsminister sich einigen
möglichst ein einheitliches vorgehen wie
wir mit reiserückkehrern am flughafen
umgehen es kommt ja nicht ganz
überraschend dass menschen aus dem
urlaub und auch aus risikogebieten
wieder nach deutschland einreisen
einreisen in pandemie zeiten flughäfen
sind das eine aber was ist mit den
touristen die per zug oder auto
zurückkommen viele fragen völlig offen
klar ist nur wer aus einem offiziellen
risikogebiet heimkehrt etwa aus der
türkei muss in quarantäne und das zwei
wochen wochen die man einplanen sollte
etwa für das thema schule lehrern
könnten sogar strafen drohen heißt es
heute aus schleswig holstein
diejenigen die dann vorsätzlich also
wissentlich in ein risikogebiet fahren
die müssen dafür sorge tragen dass sie
rechtzeitig wieder da sind damit sie die
quarantäne einheiten können
und diejenigen die das nicht tun wir
müssen damit rechnen dass sie dienst
rechtlich belangt werden und das ist
auch zu gehaltseinbußen kommen kann der
urlaub in diesem jahr voll gepackt mit
problemen wie gesagt die virus krise sie
ist immer mit dabei
wichtige infos für reisende gibt es auch
in der zdf- heute apps zb eine übersicht
welche länder ihre coroner regeln wieder
verschaffen und wo masken pflicht
herrscht um flugreisenden die sorge zu
nehmen sich auf dem weg in den urlaub
anzustecken haben sich die eu
verkehrsminister auf gemeinsame
hygienevorschriften geeinigt künftig
soll jeder passagier ab sechs jahren
einen mund nasen schutz tragen der
mittelplatz muss nicht frei bleiben
am flughafen gelten die abstandsregeln
auch bei der abfertigung
wer sich als junger mensch freiwillig
für die gesellschaft engagieren will hat
mehrere möglichkeiten bei der bundeswehr
kommt noch eine neue dazu
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer hat das projekt heute
vorgestellt es nennt sich freiwilliger
wehrdienst im heimatschutz und soll
insgesamt ein jahr dauern
teilnehmende werden nach einer
grundausbildung nur in deutschland
eingesetzt etwa bei umweltkatastrophen
oder bei der bekämpfung von pandemien
mit 1000 personen soll es losgehen
mehr hat david gebracht der wehrdienst
über jahrzehnte sollte er junge männer
für den kriegsfall schulen und mitunter
fürs leben generell manche junge mann
lernt hier so einiges was sie vielleicht
später einmal gut gebrauchen kann
zum beispiel wenn er eine frau erwischt
die von kochen weniger ahnung hat als er
doch zeiten ändern sich 2011 wird aus
der wehrpflicht ein rein freiwilliger
dienst der nachwuchssorgen beschert und
nun ergänzt werden sei ein angebot an
menschen männer und frauen egal ob jung
oder alt die sich für deutschland
engagieren wollen und es ist eine chance
für uns diesen
dazu in der bundeswehr ein weiteres
angebot zu machen
sieben monate militärische ausbildung in
den anschließenden jahren sollen weitere
fünf monate reserve dienst folgen
inklusive urlaub
auslandseinsätze soll es nicht geben
aber arbeiten in der heimat bei
naturkatastrophen etwa das reicht der
afg nicht sie will wieder eine
wehrpflicht für alle das ist der
reingewinn um die riesengroße
personallücke von 18 bis 20.000 nicht
besetzt stellen zu füllen sozialverbände
kritisieren dass ein zusätzlicher dienst
an der waffe geschaffen werde statt
soziales und ökologisches engagement zu
stärken
die prioritäten seien falsch gesetzt
zumal in zeiten wachsender probleme mit
rechtsextremismus in teilen der
bundeswehr beklagt auch die linke heimat
schutzdienst und dienst an der waffe das
zieht bestimmte kreise an eben auch
genau diese rechte kreise und die sind
nicht gewollt die sollte nicht in die
bundeswehr deshalb ist sie so dienst
kontraproduktiv ab anfang september
können sich interessenten bewerben für
einen wehrdienst im wandel der schritt
halten muss mit neuen herausforderungen
und alte traditionen nicht ganz ablegen
mag einer der vorerst letzten
ns-prozesse ist zu ende gegangen das
landgericht hamburg hat einen wachmann
des konzentrationslagers stadt hof zu
zwei jahren haft auf bewährung
verurteilt der heute 93 jährige gehörte
als jugendlicher von 1944 bis 45 zur ss
truppe des lagers dabei habe er beihilfe
zum mord an 5232 menschen geleistet so
die richter
im kz stutthof bei danzig hätten die
nazis mehr als 100.000 menschen gefangen
schätzungsweise 65 1000 von ihnen wurden
ermordet
christian bieker aus unserer rechts
redaktion ist in hamburg christian amann
ist schuldig gesprochen wegen beihilfe
zum mord an mehr als 5.000 menschen
warum bekommt er eine bewährungsstrafe
der angeklagte war damals 17 bzw 18
jahre alt deshalb erging das urteil
heute nach jugendstrafrecht obwohl der
angeklagte inzwischen 93 jahre alt ist
das gericht wirft ihm unter anderem vor
dass er sich dass er dass er für sich
keinen ausweg gesucht habe
dass er sich zum beispiel nicht an die
front habe versetzen lassen
auf der anderen seite arbeit sei das für
einen jugendlichen damals natürlich eine
sehr schwierige kaum zu bewältigende
aufgabe gewesen und er sei in seiner
entwicklung hinterher gewesen deshalb in
der summe nur eine bewährungsstrafe
was ist das besondere an diesen
schuldspruch zum ersten mal hat ein
deutsches gericht geurteilt dass es auch
dann mord ist wenn kz gefangenen nicht
zielgerichtet in einer gaskammer getötet
wurden
sondern wenn sie durch die
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen im lager
ums leben kamen also durch krankheit
durch hunger und wenn die lagerleitung
dies billigend in kauf genommen hat das
ist neu das gab es in der deutschen
rechtsprechung bislang nicht vielen dank
hamburg christian decker ein ganz
anderes urteil in freiburg dort hatten
mehrere männer nach einem discobesuch
überstunden eine 18 jährige vergewaltigt
sie war beeinträchtigt durch ecstasy und
alkohol
das verbrechen sorgte 2018 auch deshalb
für aufsehen weil zehn der elf
angeklagten männer flüchtlinge sind die
meisten von ihnen wurden heute zu
mehrjährigen haftstrafen verurteilt
simon panzer berichtet
was das opfer denkt und fühlt hat die
öffentlichkeit nie erfahren
hinter verschlossenen türen hatte die
studentin ausgesagt und ist heute der
richterspruch feld passiert das in ihrer
abwesenheit zu langjährigen haftstrafen
werden die meisten der elf angeklagten
verurteilt ich glaube man sieht heute
doch dass der rechtsstaat sich wehrhaft
zeigt sind fast 30 jahre haft verhängt
wurden insgesamt und das nicht einfach
mal im vorbeigehen sondern die kammer
hat wirklich in jedem letzten winkel
geblickt dass der sachverhalt ist so
gründlich aufgeklärt worden wie es
irgendwie gegen der sachverhalt das ist
eine serie von vergewaltigungen in einer
oktobernacht im jahr 2018
hier ist es passiert in einem waldstück
in der nähe eines freiburger clubs die
frau habe den sex gewollt das war die
verteidigungsstrategie viele angeklagter
dem er das gericht nun widersprochen wie
vorher schon die staatsanwaltschaft wie
nachvollziehbar ist dass das eine frau
wildfremde männer zehn oder noch mehr
männer auffordert mit ihr sex haben zu
wollen
in einer absolut unwirtlichen gegend
also in einem gebüsch erde sand müll
die tat hat für heftige diskussionen
gesorgt weil die meisten der angeklagten
eine fluchtgeschichte haben nun ende die
juristische aufarbeitung aber wohl nur
vorläufig wenn das die schriftliche
begründung abwarten und dann wird mein
mandant entscheiden ob er dagegen in
revision geht oder nicht
wovon ich allerdings ausgehen bis heute
leidet die frau massiv unter den folgen
der vergewaltigung zu einer zweiten
befragung im prozess war sie nicht mehr
in der lage in die usa da präsentiert
sich präsident trump im wahlkampf als
mann der recht und gesetz durchsetzt in
städten mit überdurchschnittlich hohe
gewaltkriminalität sollen nun
bundespolizisten für ruhe sorgen die
bürgermeister der betroffenen metropolen
darunter chicago wehren sich und
gerichte prüfen ob der einsatz überhaupt
verfassungskonform ist
ritter berichtet
ein garant für recht und ordnung in
dieser rolle sieht sich der us-präsident
und will jetzt durchgreifen
in drei us amerikanischen städten vor
allem von chicago zeichnet er ein
düsteres bild dort sei die gewalt
schlimmer als in afghanistan
das blutvergießen muss enden und es wird
enden meine regierung wird daran
arbeiten gefährliche straftäter zu
entfernen die von dieser todbringenden
politik von diesen tod bringen den
politikern laufen gelassen werden
die demokraten haben ihre städte nicht
im griff
also muss trump dort nun aufräumen so
seine botschaft tatsächlich ist in
chicago vor allem die bandenkriminalität
sind die morde in den vergangenen wochen
angestiegen
die bürgermeister aber befürchten dass
der präsident seine macht ausnutzt um
etwa auch gegen die antirassismus
proteste vorzugehen
der präsident kämpft offensichtlich um
sein politisches überleben also
überrascht es mich nicht dass er damit
vor allem auf demokratische
bürgermeister zielt aber das ändert
nichts daran dass wir diese
verfassungswidrigen bundes truppen nicht
wollen
die in unsere städte kommen sich unsere
bürger greifen sie einsperren und ihre
rechte verletzen
in portland oregon waren von trump
entsandte bundes einheiten teilweise
brutal gegen protestierer vorgegangen
damit habe der präsident die situation
bewusst eskalieren lassen so der vorwurf
und einen konflikt geschaffen mit dem er
wählerstimmen zurück erobern wolle
trumps umfragewerte sind zur zeit im
keller wegen seines umgangs mit der
anderen krise der korona pandemie die
zerstörung des regenwaldes ist in diesem
jahr extrem allein mit blick auf den
märz sprechen umweltschützer von 150
prozent mehr abholzungen im vergleich
zum vorjahr ein problem für den ganzen
planeten denn die tropischen regenwälder
entlang des äquators sind die natürliche
klimaanlage der erde
sie verdunsten riesige mengen an
feuchtigkeit das kühlt die atmosphäre
insgesamt denn das wasser zirkuliert und
verteilt sich weit über die regenwälder
hinaus auch als regen
dieser kreislauf wird durch abholzung
massiv bedroht christoph röck über die
situation in brasilien
die flammen wüten wieder im regenwald
aktuelle bilder von greenpeace aus dem
brasilianischen bundesstaat mato grosso
brandrodungen sind hier verboten doch
die täter haben kaum etwas zu befürchten
von anfang an hat diese regierung
versprochen umweltvergehen nicht mehr so
streng zu bestrafen
sie hat den überwachungsbehörden die
mittel gekürzt nach den verheerenden
feuern im letzten jahr hat die
regenwaldzerstörung in diesem jahr noch
einmal zugenommen
doch es gibt einen kleinen anlass zur
hoffnung investoren haben gedroht
milliarden aus brasilien abzuziehen und
dies scheint die mächtige brasilianische
agrarindustrie aufzuschrecken in den
brasilianischen medien fordern die
unternehmen die regierung zu einem
kurswechsel auf das schlechte image
brasiliens sehr schlecht fürs geschäft
das weltweite kapital ist stark von dem
umweltthema beeinflusst sagt der chef
des landwirtschaftsverbandes und
präsident bruno beschimpft zwar in einem
video für seine anhänger die europäer
als umwelt sekte gleichzeitig aber
verhängte ein viermonatiges brandrodung
verbot und schickt seinen vize general
murad samt armee in den wald zum
feuerlöschen umweltschützer sind
skeptisch doch es zeigt dass der druck
des geldes wirken kann deshalb auch
fordern einige an den freihandelszonen
zwischen europa und brasilien
festzuhalten
nur so könne man einfluss nehmen auf den
umweltschutz
der weg ist nicht der boykott sondern
mit gemeinsamen und transparenten
methoden die kontrollen zu verbessern
andernfalls würde brasilien einfach noch
mehr nach china verkaufen und dort
spielt der schutz des
amazonas-regenwaldes bisher kaum eine
rolle
ganz anderes thema jetzt eine schokolade
im quadrat darum streiten die marken
ritter sport und mika seit zehn jahren
jetzt hat der bundesgerichtshof
entschieden
die charakteristische form bleibt ritter
sport exklusiv vorbehalten
die idee stammt übrigens von firmen
mitgründerin klarer ritter sie wollte
eine schokolade produzieren die in jede
jackentasche passt
und nicht nur ritter sport hat grund zu
feiern sondern auch jürgen klopp
gestern abend haben die reds und ihre
anhänger so richtig krachen lassen
zur einstimmung ein furioser 5 zu 3 sieg
in chelsea im stadion und vor dem
stadion eine furiose meisterfeier der
fans nach 30 jahren ist der pott wieder
in der anfield road
entgegen aller abstandsregeln feiern
liverpools fenstern empfiehlt degens
meisterschaft ist noch mal was
besonderes was historisches dass jürgen
klopp damit den rats gelungen ist im
letzten heimspiel der saison gibt es
noch viele tore das schönste gegen
chelsea wohl dass einzelne lichkeit tag
aber auch die blues liefern mehr als
drei tore erzielen sie aber nicht der
ex-dortmunder politik mit dem 3 zu 4 den
schlusspunkt setzt jedoch liverpool acht
tore in einem spiel
auch das ist rekord irgendwie passend
zur meistersaison des jürgen klopp
bayern münchen muss die zukunft wohl
ohne mittelfeldstar thiago plan
vorstandschef rummenigge bestätigte
heute dass der spanier so wörtlich was
neues machen möchte bislang habe aber
noch kein klub die bayern kontaktiert
auch die zukunft von abwehrchef david
allers bayern münchen ist ungewiss
tiago hat auch der österreicher noch
einen vertrag beim fcb bis ende der
nächsten saison ja morgen sollten sie
eigentlich beginnen die olympischen
sommerspiele 2020 in tokio doch die
korona pandemie die führte zur
verschiebung um ein jahr
dass die spiele 2021 stattfinden werden
ist längst nicht sicher
wegen der korona entwicklung heute haben
die infektionszahlen mit einem
rekordanstieg ihren höhepunkt in tokio
erreicht wir brauchen verschiedene
analysen und zu beurteilen ob dies eine
zweite welle ist
wir müssen uns darauf vorbereiten japan
wird alles dafür geben und diese ränge
zu füllen und die welt zittert und hofft
mit
denn mit den spielen könnte auch ein
wenig normalität zurückkehren
ja genau heute in einem jahr wäre die
eröffnungsfeier
in einigen regionen deutschlands ist
regen immer noch mangelware und das
bedeutet trockenstress für die pflanzen
mehr dazu gleich im wetter von osten
terry christian sievers begrüßt er um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten abend bis
machen
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter trockenstress haben die pflanzen
in deutschland derzeit überall wo es
orange und rot eingefärbt ist also hier
ist viel zu wenig wasser oder fast gar
kein wasser mehr in den ersten 25
zentimeter des bodens deutlich mehr
wasser gibt es an den alpen dir hat es
ja ordentlich gewittert in den letzten
tagen und ganz im norden auch dort gab
es regen an dieser situation ändert sich
erst mal wenig das sehen sie hier ein
hoch schiebt sich wieder nach
deutschland in die mitte und hier bleibt
es trocken im norden aber regen und im
süden ebenfalls so sieht die nacht aus
da sehen sie die wolken dir 110 oder
gibt es etwas regen und auch von westner
tröpfelt ist an den alpen ebenfalls
schauer sonst trocknet es ab 9 bis 17
grad
dies werte und morgen dann war ähnliche
verteilungen hauptsächlich im norden die
wolken mit regen und gewitter zwischen
zwischen den alpen und dem bayerischen
wald dazwischen gibt es wieder
sonnenschein und es ist wieder trocken
temperaturen dazu bis 28 grad im osten
und 20 grad an den küsten die nächsten
tage am samstag noch relativ ruhiges
wetter mit einzelnen schauern bis 29
grad und sonntag kommt dann endlich
wieder regen nachschub bis 27 grad
ein schöner abend